19 people including nine children have
been killed in an apartment fire in new
york city in what's been described as
one of the worst fires in recent memory
fire department of new york commissioner
dan negro spoke to the media about the
fire
units arrived here this morning within
three minutes of the call for a fire
that was in a duplex apartment this
apartment spanned floors two and three
they were met in the hallway with this
fire
very heavy smoke very heavy fire units
pushed in this smoke extended
the entire height of the building
completely unusual members found victims
on
every floor in stairwells and we're
taking them out
in cardiac and respiratory arrest we
won't know the total yet of the outcome
but we do know that as the mayor stated
32 people
were transported to hospitals and
life-threatening conditions
let's speak now to eddie brown a
firefighter who is at the scene of the
fire at home now off-duty um thank you
for speaking to us eddie um it must have
been an awful scene to approach
yes i am i am with the union so i i went
there in a capacity i was off duty so i
went there to just check on the scene
see what was happening and to see how
my guys and
men and women were doing from the box
fire department and uh it was a horrific
scene because you have to realize
besides being a firefighter you have to
deal with the mental stress of seeing
this carnage of what happened in the
bronx today and how did your colleagues
deal with what they found
ah they dealt with it you know i can't
speak for them but i've seen a lot of
young people young younger firefighters
that have been in this situation before
and they have that look to their face
you know it's it's a stressful job but
you know you deal with it and your job
is to get the task at hand to try to
rescue as many people as you can
so what did you actually see yourself
i just i spoke to a lot of people there
and you know there was uh 32 people
brought to the hospital and they were
like you know we ladder all the we try
to ladder as much as we can to get
victims out and there was uh just a lot
when by the time i got there they had
knocked the fire down that's all our
language for putting it out was knocked
down and the firefighters were all
outside still doing their jobs doing
searches of the building the problem was
that the door was left open
in the fire apartment which
contaminated the whole building with
smoke 19 stories high
wow and and approximately we're hearing
the detail that's come through to us
approximately 200 firefighters responded
to this incident
yes yes
what will be the procedure now at the
scene
it's just gonna be
it's gonna pretty much our job is is is
gonna be done it's gonna be to get the
people that live in the building
into a warm shelter where they can live
because right now if you see many of the
windows are broken and a lot of those
hyper floor windows were broken by the
civilians themselves
trying to get air but actually that's
actually the opposite of what you should
do
a lot of people would have been safer if
they would have stayed in their
apartments
once you go into the hallway and that
door was left open you're going out into
the smoke so a lot of times you're
better off staying in your apartment and
trying to take the bottom of the door or
put a rag there or something like that
to stop the smoke from coming in
okay eddie we've got um some pictures
that that you uh filmed we're looking at
those now just um showing us around the
scene this presumably is when you you
first arrived
yes
so i don't know if you're able to see
them can you talk us through
what's actually filming walking down the
block as you can see that we have the
one big ladder there that's called an
aerial ladder that's part of the truck
that's going right into the fire
apartment where the fire started and
that's where the firefighters would go
up and try to pull people out and then
you see the smaller ladders there are
the other windows those are called
portable laps which the members take off
the trucks and they put them up and it's
an attack basically we attack them fire
so we have people coming in with hose
lines from the interior to burn the fire
out but as we do it the latter companies
are going throughout the building with
ladders and inside the building trying
to rescue victims as we go along
yes we can see your footage uh there and
and just to sort of recap on what you
were saying before that that potentially
people might have been safer to stay in
in the block rather than try and exit
yeah another a lot of it's it's human
nature to try to run out of of your if
it's those are fire proof buildings so
if you stay in your hallway people if
you stay in your apartment you're
probably safer the people that ran into
the stairwells which were filled with
smoke were putting themselves in more
danger
okay eddie thanks so much for uh
speaking to us and giving us your
perspective on this horrific fire eddie
brown firefighter who was at the scene
thank you
thanks